one of the things that was disconcerting
to us and in me in particular because I
came from a layout department
is that you had to two very distinct
departments in the CG pipeline in the
layout department and then lighting
department layout would choose they
would ultimately choose the compositions
the lenses the camera movements and then
separated by months in the production
line like after the animation had been
created you would have lighting who had
come in and then they would sort of set
up lights and cast shadows we talked
about bringing in a cinematographer that
everybody with respect and whose career
you know was an exemplary one like Roger
Deakins and our list was very short to
come in and talk to everybody but
specifically those two departments about
about marrying their their thinking so
that everybody in the layout department
knew what the lighters were thinking
before they settled on compositions and
and that's when we brought Roger into
the mix we knew that he had done a
little work on Wally and so he was
familiar with the with computer
animation and the limitations and the
great benefits of it and he sat down and
we kind of wanted to do something
similar where you know could you spend a
couple days with us and and just do
these workshops and perhaps he
misunderstood because he went away and
then he came back to as a couple days
and we heard through our producer Bonnie
that he wants to join for the entire
film I mean he wants to to be kind of a
consulting cinematographer for the
entire film which we kind of tossed her
cookies in the air and we were very
excited about because we it meant that
he was able to touch every frame of the
film with his with his taste and his
influence and and Dean and I went to one
of our test screenings and Tom we're
sitting the very very back of the of the
theater and there was this shot that
that was it was a cool shot it was a
shot where the dragon was flying
straight up and he was firing some a big
pillar of fire at at a hiccup on and and
toothless and and on the storyboard it
was it was neat on the storyboard is
cool you know and an animation is really
neat because just wow the scale came in
but the other end unsung here is this
whole thing I think our effects team and
we were sitting in the back of the
theater watching the movie and watching
for people's reactions and that scene
rolled by and it had been finished and
lit with the
facts and it just was suddenly massive
in this dragon was flying up cutting
through his own pillow fire with his
wing and he's just like oh wow we
screamed really loud I was like you mine
ha the story originally was written
between 1956 in 1959 by the great
filmmaker and French actor Jacques Tati
and tatty has a special place in the
hearts of people who adore French cinema
is sort of an equivalent of a Buster
Keaton or a chaplain and it was a very
iconic figure in in French film and
apparently a show may saw the red this
original story and thought it would have
been a great to be made into an animated
film interesting thing is that tatty
didn't really think of it as a comedy he
really he kind of wrote it as a love
letter to his to one of his daughters
and when when Shan Mei was doing
triplets of belleville in 2003 there was
a scene where some of the characters
were sitting watching television and he
thought it would have been fun to put a
live-action thing on the television
instead of its always human you know
live-action characters watching
animation on TV he'd have been fun to
have a cartoon sitting and watching live
action on television so so at first he
was going to put something from the Tour
de France and then he thought well let
me put some of Monsieur helos holiday in
there and and and the his producer in
the process of getting the rights to use
the the tatty footage befriended the
surviving daughter I knew so Sasha
touchy Jeff and and she granted
permission to use them to use the story
wholeheartedly and thought it was a
great idea that would be made into an
animated film the film was mostly
animated in edinboro which is
interesting because it's not really
known for animation anything a Sylvan
located the studio there but he said
that during one of the film festivals at
the Admiral film festival when they
premiered triplets of belleville he fell
in love with the place and love the
constantly changing lie
in the colors and the Scottish
countryside also what's interesting was
that there was an animator working on it
named Victor ends who was originally a
bus driver in bonn germany and
apparently that he was sort of
discovered on this film they found that
he could draw an animate and he wound up
doing a lot of terrific footage
including the scottish drunk and the
opera singer sounds wonderful stuff we
just knew in our hearts we wanted to
make another toy story and we knew that
there was something out there we just
didn't quite know what it was so we
gathered together John Lasseter and P
dr. Andrew and I at this little cabin
where they had come up with the idea for
the first toy or and we locked ourselves
away for two days with the goal of
coming up with a rock solid idea for a
toy story 3 and we came up with a lot of
things in those two days that ended up
in the movie but the main thing that we
came up with it was making this decision
to have Andy grown-up it just felt right
because so many years had gone by even
though it was a little weird in
animation to have characters age Lee in
the world of The Simpsons obviously
nobody ever ages but for us it felt
right because we had been living Our
Lives you know we had been raising our
families we had lost friends you know we
lost our buddy Joe ramped who was a big
part of all the early movies you know we
just had been experiencing a lot a lot
of life and it only felt right to to do
that with with the with the characters
as well and have a lot of time have
passed at the very end after Andy gets
back in the car and he kind of turns
back and looks at the toys one last time
and that was a moment that was inspired
by my grandmother when I was making the
first toy story my grandmother got
cancer and she went pretty quickly but I
had an opportunity to fly home and see
her and I knew I was seeing her for the
last time she was she was gravely ill
though in good spirits but I knew that
this was my last trip to see her and
there was a moment at the end of the
trip where my grandmother was at a
restaurant and I said goodbye to her I
gave her a hug I knew that I was truly
saying goodbye to her
and though she didn't seem to be aware
of the moment she was just smiling and
talking to friends and then I I left the
restaurant I stopped in the doorway with
my wife and I turned back and I looked
at my grandmother one last time and I
kind of took a mental snapshot of her
smiling up at a friend and and then I I
stored that away i still have it and i
turned away and left and when we were
boarding the scene you know I I pitched
this not only to my storyboard artist
but also to the animators when we
animated the scene and I think that it
gives that moment where he turns back
and looks at the toys kind of a
resonance and a richness that it
wouldn't have had if I had just you know
said well I and II looks back at the
toys and and looks at them one last time
you